morning everyone good morning to my
favorite Millennials our favorite and
only me Lenny I'm completely broken
like not even hungover so much just like
dead tired a physical pain like yeah if
I have to walk somewhere I'm just not
going it's
it's so sad I'm not gonna make it but I
don't know why like if we break it down
I don't know why I should be so tired
because I wouldn't is sleeping like one
o'clock good normal hour if out if I
have a late TV night mm-hmm I woke up
later than I usually do for the show
same I slept more last night that I did
any night this week yet a much higher
this night different from all other
night I have no idea and like I just
find it fascinating that like as human
beings we haven't figured out like how
not to be tired yet like we've figured
out a hack for everything like you can't
in your shirt into like a gun you know
like you're always doing [ __ ] like that
on the internet like I want a video on
how not to be tired like how to make
morning like how to wake up excited and
happy feel like how do you just wake up
like this or how do you just wake up
like oh it's time to get up yeah
walk walk walk no there are people who
don't set alarms and they're like yeah
my body wakes me up and I'm like you're
a liar
yeah my body wakes me up at 2:00 p.m. ya
know my body's my alarm no it's not
[ __ ] my alarm is my alarm like that's
just what makes the weekend so precious
and I'm 1 and I couldn't help but wonder
if we did this show in the afternoon and
we could wake up at our leisure like
would we be happier people I don't know
because I there's something really
degenerate about not having to wake up
and so we might actually be the opposite
of happy or we might be like less sad
and like depressed if we wake up so late
and we have such a short day with little
daylight but the reason why we're so
tired it's cuz we had an action-packed
night we hung out with the cast of
southern charm who had just finished
wrapping their reunion we got an
exclusive photo of all our outfits them
at the Reunion nobody has this photo I
just want to feel like I'm super proud
of the fact that we salute star way to
get it honestly it was all you so I'm
proud of you you guys can see it here
here are my initial thoughts Catherine
is way overdressed
she always is that's her thing yes she
looks great
I think Naomi was like right in the
middle of like cam looked super relaxed
she's a mom and I she has more important
things to do
and Catherine was like going to the
Royal Wedding so like Naomi was right in
the middle of the fanciness yeah but
that's that's on par for all reunions
and their personalities and I feel like
Naomi just like looks like perfect like
she's going to like college formal yeah
and she's the best dress you know
returning the sweetheart I can't divulge
too much but here's what we found out a
few things Craig and Naomi had some
words you know that's what happens when
you love someone you still have someone
Ashley in Austin never gonna happen
like we we pleaded we were like please
just get together they they couldn't be
less interested in each other yeah I
don't know what I'm seeing on TV like it
is me question like either my perception
or maybe it's just television and like
that's the thing about television I'm
glad that that you know you have this
love story on television Ashley showed
up for a decent sized portion she's
staying in a different hotel than
everyone like they have not had any
communication with her Thomas was not at
the reunion because he's a sexual
alligator that's laughing an alligator
and apparently what happened with Ashley
is she's still quite um delusional she
said she's not sorry for what she said
but just where she said it will get to
you everything it will get to see
everything and I'm very much looking
forward to I don't think they
under-deliver no they never do it no
such an underrated show and I just love
the whole cast and we agreed to us with
them last night and that's how we're
broken but you know it was Grayson okay
for we're never having it at any time
yeah we just kept being like we're
hosting like we were the host and we are
going to Charleston I'm so confused like
that's why I paused yeah we're having
the calling to Charleston really near
each other they're bringing the toast
live Naomi said they're three hours
apart so I got a map though but they're
both in the Carolinas okay well it was
really a toast to Charleston
so gird your loins a great night was had
by all I'm ready to move on I'm ready to
move on to to some mediocre news of the
day yeah nothing good nothing too big
and like honestly I'm really conserving
my energy because
as you guys know we have a podcast
special episode coming up tonight at one
o'clock Jack and I will be interviewing
one of our personal heroes I don't know
his real name
but Andy Anderson yeah and he hit Enter
said he is entertainment lawyer Andy on
Twitter he created blind items he's a
personal hero of mine and we're really
excited to get to talk to him we have a
list of things we want to talk to him
about as always feel free to comment on
things that you want to hear about but
obviously Dan Schneider all that good
stuff usually suspects yes will be
discussed Selina all that oh my god oh
my god own Hermes I posted a meme about
Selena Gomez what oh that's just
terrible out everything yeah the
comments oh my god people are like I
feel so sorry for you like you don't
make 1/100 of her income that she makes
in one episode of 13 reasons why
speaking of 13 reasons why I finished
season two last night and I really urge
you guys not to watch our show first how
many reasons and now I know that saying
that is gonna make you want to watch it
more I a after spending like so long
watching these long confusing grey
boring episodes I feel like I wasted so
much time I got nothing out of it and I
had two major problems there's one
graphic scene that everyone's talking
about which here spoil everyone named
Claudia Asha has been talking about if
you don't spoil and okay if you don't
want to hear this part just know I'm
giving you I'm giving you a warning cuz
that it's pertinent to the argument
Claudia but like some people okay ready
go Joe I'm saying it I don't I'm saying
about warning you he gets a broom shoved
up his ass in school by some bullies and
it was so graphic and so vulgar and so
unnecessary they were making the school
of me and member talking about it I
understand that bullying is a really big
problem I and I don't know because I'm
not in middle school anymore but I have
a hard time believing it gets to the
level that it gets in that school they
were making it seem like the school was
a prison where like people were getting
sodomized and like gay men in middle
sameen in hyper high schools yeah people
get autumn eyes it doesn't happen every
day in every high school but there are
stories and that has got eyes really
yeah brooms up the ass they get they
didn't invent that Jackie Prison did and
then wait they take people and they put
bags over their heads and like kidnap
them and beat them up that's not what it
happens like that happens in prison
where do they take them in prison you
think the prisoners have such like yes
RT
yes no it felt like an episode of
oranges new black
and then this is the best part at the
very end we knew what exactly was gonna
happen this kid who got sodomized he was
bullied so hard he was completely like
nowhere else to turn so he decided to
shoot up his school which he's not even
like a right line of thinking like Oh
someone was busy tonight yep I'm gonna
go shoot up my school like No then they
know he's coming and they don't call the
cops and they're urging everyone not to
call the cops
let's go talk to him are you kidding me
like I literally as watching it I'm like
I was literally as if something that's
like I'm completely done with the shell
clay Jensen is a [ __ ] [ __ ] and the
most annoying kid on earth and I just oh
and like they're shooting heroin in
their toes it's prison it's drugs in
prison yes you can
it's a huge market no it's not Jackie
you need to watch our just new black oh
yeah it happened like you hear stories
it's horrible story Craig the football
team getting out some of their like
masculine anger I don't know it was
unnecessary to it was very vulgar it's
like a kids show
I can't well I'm just glad when all of
the buzz was surrounding it last season
I chose not to watch therefore I don't
have to watch a season two and I'm just
I'm officially done with that Jo it's so
bad and it sends so many bad messages
and when everyone was saying after the
first season that like it glorifies and
romanticizes suicide I was like you know
what I'll give another chance but
they're right everything about the show
is horrible including the music okay and
the producer yeah okay oh and then they
have this thing called after the reasons
which is like a talk show to talk about
the problems and it's like after Dale
it's like you take a big dump yeah you
take a big dump and make all these like
huge blanket statements and now you want
to talk about it like please
I can't so you're a big fan of Selena
Gomez and her work horrible I will
literally never watch it well I will it
truly he's never watch it it's so bad
well I'm glad you've come to that
conclusion
I've been busy finishing Sex in the City
and I have
be honest the episode the second-to-last
episode is the greatest episode of the
whole series because Kari goes to Paris
gets her ass handed to her by the city
of Paris and it was just it was so
justified for years of watching her
labelling to put up with her [ __ ]
and like she really acts like a 40 year
old child and it's so annoying she's
like Eloise at the Piazza and she's 40
and it's unbearable but I'm glad to be
done with it and moving on with my life
anyway so are you ready for the past
five stories that you need to know
before you wake up and take a bite out
of your morning toast II know you're
Eddie took a bite I'd be more into
choice cause I felt I feel bad now that
I'm doubting sodomy but this is what I
wasn't saying that I'm just saying like
it was highly unnecessary you're giving
kids ideas of how to bully each other
shouting sodomy I know that it happens I
understand why you why you feel bad yeah
no I'm not I don't want to doubt
anyone's experiences but all I'm saying
it's like the scene was so unnecessary
so vulgar and it's like they needed
their show to be relevant so they did
something crazy because there was
nothing else noteworthy about the whole
season okay
fair okay first up Angela Angelina Jolie
could lose primary custody of her kids
if Brad Pitt isn't allowed access as a
report Angelina Jolie is in danger of
losing primary custody of her six
children to a strange husband Brad Pitt
according to court documents obtained by
the blast this could occur if she
doesn't take steps to improve their
relationship with their father a judge
in the couple's ongoing divorce said the
six children quote not having a
relationship with their father is
harmful to them adding that it is
critical that each of them have a
healthy and strong relationship with
their father and mother
furthermore the judge said in court
documents if the minor children remain
closed down to their father and
depending on the circumstances
surrounding his condition and may result
in a reduction of the time they spend
with Jolie and may result in the court
ordering primary physical custody to
Pitt that's so interesting
so like usually when people get divorced
and looks like a custody battle
I always side with the mom like Lily
from Gossip Girl Kelly Rutherford like
what she went through was horrible I'm
just gonna come right out and say it
like Angelina Jolie is very concerning
and I don't feel safe in her arms do you
not I mean yes and no I just I think
that boat both parents seem like good
people just cuz like Brad Pitt got drunk
on a plane or something like he didn't
get custody but why can't they have
shared custody like equal
it's like truly why can't we all just
get along truly they got along for so
long like can't we just extend it a
little more until your kids turn 18 I
know and like Maddox is already up there
mm-hmm
it's just so crazy like I feel old when
I see like celebrity kids like grown the
[ __ ] up yeah they are like a true
testament to like how long I've been
alive has passed
yeah and like how long I've been
intrigued with like Hollywood yeah
there's no one I think like I remember
the day Maddox got adopted
ya know I feel like Suri Cruise is gonna
be like when she like started hitting
the scene like kya Gerber's totally I'm
gonna just have to retire completely Oh
Kai Gerber was out the rest Marella's me
and so was Presley is that Preston Oh
her brother yeah presently
plot she's Mitch's Angels watches which
is eight now watching worst heartburn
cuz I had margaritas ah same margaritas
and I need a tongue and I have so many
at my house oh because they sent you
yeah and like snitch and you feel your
heart burn in your back yes oh my god
yes I do
it the heartburn woke me up in the
middle of a night okay I don't know what
to tell you other than power through
cysts and hates his sister miss you sis
Missy says that new Josh Groban song
though nothing like it everyone should
take a listen
did you watch the Tonys no no me neither
I haven't watched the Tonys ever since
Liam trauma though I haven't watched the
Tonys ever since slay Michelle sing to
Iran and my parade and walk down the
aisle and sing in front of Beyonce and
jay-z I just think we could never
achieve such Broadway magic that it
would just be useless for me to even
pretend okay sure um next story another
just development in the ongoing love
story but more talking about Chloe
interest in every single day from now
that Ariana and who I actually prefer to
talk about Pinot Grigio of course
because like Chloe interesting they felt
like there was so much that we did it
now and so much misinformation like my
thoughts on Instagram exactly and you
just can't trust the thoughts on
Instagram but I feel like Ariana and
Pete it's pretty much out there you what
you see is what you get right I don't
yeah
Ariana Grande
Davidson he dropped nearly $100,000 on
an engagement ring
it is a pear-shaped diamond with a halo
and a diamond pave band he's okay there
are pictures surfacing on Twitter of her
wearing that ring like years ago know at
the I heart Wango team no no no I saw
this morning yes apparently she's been
wearing this engagement ring for like a
week and like secretly nobody knew about
it but there are old pictures of her on
social media wearing a very similar
looking ring they're like lmao
ariana grande has been engaged since
2016 oh that's so interesting but maybe
she just got it for like a little rain
Schwartz they lent it to her first yeah
and they wear like big-time and actually
I fell in love with it and that became
like her shaped choice yeah or teardrop
because she has no tears left to cry
someone was like is Pete Davidson that
rich oh my god I had the funniest thing
Shia Davidson does well and wait I have
the funniest thing to tell you can I
read so me and Jackie got a DM on the
morning breath Facebook page yesterday
and like usually I don't want to lose
today it's it's not a big deal it's been
so long it's been so you're human all
the southern charmers were calling it
the morning breath yesterday I just like
was letting imaginations Claudia you're
human
okay so I house don't do this
conversation we had with this girl this
girl was like DMing us complaining about
the toast and like usually I don't
answer but like this was such an
unreasonable like if you want to say you
guys are ignorant and spread
misinformation like okay you wouldn't be
wrong like did you do that like this
girl's argument was so thin and I was
just like I wanted to [ __ ] with her so I
did I won't say your name alright what
said you can say your name I'm getting
okay so it's so long as she goes I just
wanted to let you guys know your most
recent show has made me stop watching
you aren't getting back to you soon
enough because I can't stand watching
your rude comments but listen to what
I'm saying because you can fix this so
I'm like [ __ ] what do we do you guys are
really naive the information you spread
is so incorrect and I was like oh [ __ ]
what I said what did we get wrong what
Roman Polanski what blind item yes did
we make up Pete Davidson does not work
one night a week do you not realize that
every [ __ ] member of SNL works all
week to help writers write the sketch
and rehearse it's not an easy job your
job is easy in my opinion and you
complain about it why be more grateful
for your life do you not realize that
you make more money doing these whatever
I said hey are ya that was a joke
we obviously know he works more than one
hour a week the shifts to hours our show
is comedic don't take anything too
seriously first time I'm indulging yeah
whatever I'm happy you have such a great
job also I do have one more thing I know
it's comedy but you joke about
disposable cups it's ridiculous I'm not
going to watch you not get do not get it
I get that it's a comedy but you
actually seem really rude and I was like
I literally was just responding like a
bro but I'm like oh yeah just laugh and
enjoy it's a comedy thanks for watching
thanks for support we really appreciate
the support let me know if I can help
with anything else
do you not realize how bad that would be
for the environment I'm so glad bed is
not using disposable cups please just
get over it I was like see you tomorrow
10:30 a.m. needs to be done so I'm sure
she's watching hello REM oh my god it
was honestly like the greatest exchange
of my life
and I did it obviously but I was
watching 13 reasons why because I was
bored out of my mind
um so Pete Davidson apparently does have
a job and money he opens for he does
can't stand up he opens for Dave
Chappelle yesterday right and then
someone else I killed an on it I think
it might've been Arya I'm the YouTube
company so that seems like a lucrative
gig and lucrative enough for him to pick
up a $93,000 BBS one clarity 3.0 three
carat diamond set in platinum last month
we're told it was made especially for
Ariana and took nearly two weeks to
complete so if you do the math he got it
commissioned two weeks after they
started burning and gave it to her two
weeks later okay but like here's the
thing he's still on the up and up and I
just feel like financially this is not a
smart move like he definitely as a
financial manager cuz everyone in
Hollywood does and he's probably really
unhappy with him but it's an investment
like technically your money's still
there it's different than spending like
ninety two thousand dollars on a night
out or wore like a car that like
depreciates over time yeah like this is
I guess I don't think it's a bad money
move and I think I'm sure he's doing
fine I'm doin son someone says his net
worth is five hundred thousand so you're
spending you're spending twenty five or
twenty percent one one says 20 percent
of your net worth on a ring not smart
okay but like do you believe networks
calm no courts are calm says my net
worth his children something about
thousand dollars and that couldn't be
further so you're where
half of Pete Davidson but maybe they
valued like my Instagram account I
thought like if someone's by my
Instagram account I would make them pay
like at least $275,000 um no I don't
think that's how it works no net worth
com I think they just pull [ __ ] out of
there I don't know but it's like value
of your your assets literally the only
thing I own is my business I don't think
that they are and the tous is a two
million dollar show so of course course
ah so should really be more I don't
think that they are qualified to
evaluate instagrams you know totally
another long if they come it's a fake
website now there are some legit
websites rich love dominant the only
time I feel like it's legit is like when
it's about people in business market
salaries are public yep whose input like
who own companies that are public
therefore the information is public so
it's so funny like if they break up like
you have to give it back and this girl
Wendy said if you get proposed to you on
a national holiday it's considered a
gift and you don't have to give the ring
back genius so once you get like engage
in July 4th I got engaged on June 9th
oh my god that's literally the craziest
thing I've ever heard
genius genius so maybe like ariana
chipped in you never know maybe they
like already sharing cash like is the
jeweler public like are they being
thottie on Instagram the jeweler um cuz
it could have gotten Jessica it looks
like they're being patty but I'm not
seeing a name so how thought he could
they be true yeah like Jax definitely
didn't pay full retail for that Kyle
chanda's ein ring no and also it's like
the inflation around these ring prices
like all these kneeling rings from The
Bachelor worth a hundred thousand
dollars like they're not that's what
he's charged with
yeah like but the diamond itself and
like the it's probably worth like around
20k so they didn't no one paid a hundred
thousand and no one's gonna pay a
hundred thousand do you know what I mean
so maybe like this jeweler said it's 93
thousand dollar ring but is it the world
might never know the world may never
know anyways I'm still happy for them
and I'm just living I'm gonna I'm here
and I'm happy for them I'm just I get a
small pit about it and I'm a little
concerned about like both their well
beings yeah
same but like for now it's good and like
I enjoy talking about them meet you but
the barns don't lie ok we'll have to ask
NT about it for today I'm just like
Pittsville central about this anti
interview
because it could be our last right so
like I said just a quick reminder if
Jackie and I mysteriously go missing or
something happened so I think happens
whether we get murdered like just know
and they make it seem like a suicide or
something like we didn't want this so if
something happens to us and please know
who's responsible Hollywood next story
in a case of justice being served which
we just love a good serving of justice
love a good case of justice desk
co-founder Marciano steps down amid
sexual harassment claims thank God
the guest ink models are vindicated Kate
Upton to Paul Marciano the co-founder
and executive chairman of the 37
year-old apparel brand is stepping down
the company said Tuesday four months
after model Kate Upton and others
accused him of sexual harassment a four
month pro by an independent board
committee found that Marciano quote
exercised poor judgment in his
communication with models and
photographers and in placing himself in
situations in which plausible
allegations of improper conduct could
and did arise I mean he did way more
than that but sure yeah like what a
bullshit-ass corporate jargon oh he
could have said something out of line he
putting themselves in a position say
something that could be deemed
inappropriate no he just was
inappropriate you know and then he
hooked that model up to go out with
Mohamed Hadid who like Shh remember that
yeah that was crazy and like so not cool
I'm so glad that this is marciano thing
is it's crumbling the allegations
included quote inappropriate comments
and text and unwanted advances including
kissing and groping the company said
marciana will remain on the board until
January 30th his brother Maurice
Marciano was appointed chairman I'm
assuming maurices last name is Marciano
because it's my brother this is brother
but maybe got married and took it
maybe his husband's last name perhaps
but I like Maurice Marciano Jimmy I
don't know anything about the man On
January 30th up Deena former guest model
said that Paul Marciano verbally
harassed and touched her inappropriately
starting when she was 18 he denied the
allegations but two weeks after they
were leveled Marciano stepped down from
his day-to-day duties to avoid
litigation guessing Marciano settle
claims with five people who claimed they
were subject to inappropriate behavior
paying each half a million dollars oh my
god I [ __ ] love Kate Upton like
nothing she does could ever be wrong in
my eyes and then like him saying that
like everyone's a liar did you see the
whirring she posted up her boob uh-huh
it was everything she's the best boobs
she really does I wonder if that was
like the first take or if it like she
had like she got nipple in a future yeah
you do it she doesn't seem like a
one-take kind of gal no but like she
also does you know she's so just
effortlessly beautiful I don't try so
hard for her content and there's still
me like Instagram thoughts these days
were just trying so hard to be here like
there can only be one to Kate Upton yeah
and her name is Kate Upton I'm happy for
her and for all of the justice that's
being served
honestly 2017 was the beginning but 2018
has truly been the year of justice being
served yes and no it's there's still so
much justice like when there's a heaping
of justice to be served and you know
three justices are served and it's not
really about the serving size it's not
the whole box it's like a quarter cup of
justice totally but better than no
justice horse okay next story is one
about one of my favorite people oh you
look like Sue Sylvester today I know I
love her so do any Sue Sylvester right I
am in love with Jane Lynch I think she's
an underrated actor and just like her
woman of our time a green and like to me
she doesn't get nearly enough work and
then she was for a while and I feel like
I feel like she chose to take a back
seat that's possible but I think she's
better in her old age than she is in her
young and I think she should be more of
like an Ellen type like when ship with a
host of the People's Choice Awards like
she could do so much better than that
like she needs a daytime show I guess is
for Jane Lynch I don't know but then
like you have a daytime show and if it's
not a success and like you're Bethenny
yeah or Kris Jenner yeah Tyra Kris
Jenner having a reality show I mean
sorry a talk show that failed was like
the most shocking thing ever did is she
pulled out all the stops oh my god I
bear what was it called
Kris oh my god I she recreated her
living room remember like those black
and white floors in her entryway that
was her set that's so crazy I mean it
wasn't the right she and Kanye on any
today it would have worked she wasn't as
famous then as she is now but still like
it shouldn't require him it being a talk
show host is such a delicate thing and
it's interesting to see who's successful
like right now Harry Connick jr. has a
shower
yep does it do what is it going well I
watch it at the nail
a few times and I love him and he looks
so hot I feel like so many people love
him yeah I do
so many people love Tyra so many people
love Bethany but see here's the thing
being a funny cool interesting person
doesn't make for a great talk show host
being a talk show host is about being a
host listening to others right but also
you can't be you have to have some sort
of Flair and uniqueness otherwise why
was your show but the majority of your
shtick has to be like listening and
provoking thought-provoking question and
a balance is for sure Harry Connick Jr's
show has been cancelled since but it
will be filmed through September for
anyone that's hilarious
anyone who wants to get their last licks
in have you ever been to like a talk
show taping no never I went to Jerry
Springer I don't think that counts I
don't think I would want to go to a
taping cuz one I'm gonna see how fake it
all is I don't like to pull back the
curtain and to I feel like there's a lot
of waiting around and I'm just not
interested you'll do i bright colors
that's the worst part and like there's
no concession stands no maybe they give
you like your bottle or water to you
before like I'm good I'd rather eat on
my couch and watch a show yeah and
fast-forward totally anyways what's next
one of my favorite actors another
underrated soul Stanley Tucci and
Felicity Blunt welcome daughter Amelia
Giovanna he is married to Emily Blunt
sister and that's probably the weirdest
thing of all time she's like a super
successful like the job that Kelsey
analyzed I have in younger it's like
what she does in real life yeah I think
she's like a really famous like book
editor book publisher in London I love
these two I love sailing cheetah memory
when I was convinced I was sitting next
to him on the plane oh my god we were
sitting in coach and yes it was going
back to New York it was definitely a
star-studded plane but Jackie was like
texting our chat like I'm a hundred
percent sitting next to Stanley Tucci
and we were all like freaking out me get
up and it's just not him like I don't
and I was watching spotlight oh my
wife's pot laying next to him to like
see if it wasn't me like what did you
think about my work I'm constantly
surprised I think GG is not gay he was
very humble I'm constantly surprised
that Stan detailing
Stanley Tucci isn't gay because he was
so good at playing a gay character and
Devil Wears Prada it was too real yeah I
feel that oh my god I'm just loving this
couple what an underrated butt
like know what a socialite like vibe but
also like low-key like not no offense
like Emily and John could like learn
something
except they tried to be low-key I just
say yeah let's not start reeling on them
yet they're doing a good job so far you
know who's really starting to piss me
off like I saw a tweet of theirs this
morning who Ryan Reynolds Oh just start
annoying and like I hate that everything
he does like enews posts like he's like
the second coming of Christ it's so
annoying he's not funny
and like he just has such a thirst
monster and why is his Twitter Vancity
Reynolds I don't know I I'm not into him
like at all
let's ask Andy about yeah because he's
apparently like keeps Blake Lively in a
cage someone else said that too I know
yeah I know that we made up in a cage
because from when we were kids yeah we
had a running joke but no there is a
blind that like she's not allowed to
work unless he has her / she has his
explicit permission but someone else was
talking about the two of them and used
the same exact language that she's in a
cage in a cage so oh maybe she is did
you ever you wouldn't really like love
SVU growing up and now I'm kind of like
hardened to up a night when I used to
watch SVU growing I'll talk about the
chongo bed I'm going did you know
because the last time we talked about
Blake Lively being in the cage you
talked about this episode of SVU I did
you're the amazing memory you're like a
memorial i'm memoria yeah yeah i didn't
did say that thing about the airplanes
no I said by that statement I did not
I'm gonna say the story anyway because
we have new listeners because we're
getting so popular whatever um cuz we're
getting so popular she lies to herself
so like now I can watch an episode and
SVU and like it doesn't really get to me
but when they were really scary and I
was a kid like I literally wouldn't be
able to sleep at night and there are two
episodes that really stuck with me one
is when mercial Hargitay goes undercover
in prison and there's like a guard who's
raping everyone and like she's supposed
to expose him but the [ __ ] iced tea
is in line to get his shot and he
doesn't get there in time and she has to
fight him off herself and she knows that
it's him because he's a big mole on his
penis but that's not that said I'm
talking about this was a super old
episode where like this nanny like
you're giving me a pit legitly she goes
missing or something she's like far in
and she like works for this rich family
on the Upper East Side and they finally
find her after like so long and she's
like been in the house the whole time
like
under a bed they pull out the it's like
a bed with storage and they pull out the
drawer and she's a loach it in a cage
and I'm like holy [ __ ] like what a
[ __ ] up person thinks about that like
who created that yeah Hollywood [ __ ]
Hollywood okay congratulations to
Stanley Tucci and Felicity Bunn all the
well wishes last final story before we
head into the air toasters teresa
giudice quote I love how body building
has transformed my body she is on the
cover of Us Weekly in a lime-green
two-piece set with lime green weights
looking fabulous but you just never
thought like at some of the darkest days
in prison like she never thought she
would get to this place and I'm so happy
for her for have gotten here yeah I feel
like even like her and Tamra outside of
prison like knowing that you're gonna be
at your peak physical self in your 40s
is like who would have thunk but like
every celebrity these days is like
prettier and skinnier in their 50s and
they are looking over to him quite as
Paltrow I just literally the other day
anomaly and I saw the show a beautiful
picture of Gwyneth Paltrow I've ever
seen and I was literally like it took my
breath away I was like recent or recent
like Joe groom diem did to me he was
like she looks so beautiful I was like
like like not human maybe she's the
exception not the rule
I feel like everyone else is just using
like modern technology and Ramona and
they look amazing which is really like
hopeful but all you can get looks better
than she looked when she was 25 yeah but
it's like because these people aren't
like naturally beautiful but like they
are naturally beautiful but they're
preserving their beauty ya know it must
be nice yeah I mean that could be us
it's actually so crazy how I think about
I assume the Kardashians for some reason
I feel like they're all like 25 but
there are a lot of him are like almost
40 no I was thinking about this morning
that Kim didn't get really famous until
she was like 20 yeah Courtney was 30 and
Courtney's about to turn 40 mm-hmm it's
just it's too much I know but I'm happy
for them that's so you never know like
Asia is no limit and I always um before
I was like a big Stan of theirs I like
always not Chloe was oldest but just
because she's the tallest yeah that's
like people think that you're old
than me yeah it's just before you're
informed mm-hmm um also Vancity stands
for vancouver where he I don't care well
you just wanted to know no this is
stupid and why are a that should be my
name great I bet it taken anyway so
Theresa after placing third in her very
first bodybuilding competition on June
9th Theresa has quote never felt so
confident the 46 year old has had it
rough in the past few years she returned
home from an eleventh month prisons day
in December 2015 saw her husband Joe off
to serve his 41-month sentence in March
and buried her Milaap beloved mother one
year later
why is bodybuilding becoming like a
trend for housewives I think it's just
like a way to you know get control over
I think it's the other thing I don't
think it's but why can't you just be in
shape without looking scary it's nice to
have a goal like personally I if I was
like on this path which you know is a
noble and righteous one I don't think I
would want to be a bodybuilder I think
I'd want to like accomplish like a Tough
Mudder or run the marathon or like a
beauty pageant but I guess this is like
their equipment running the marathon by
the way they're taking swimsuit
competition out of Miss USA so I could
finally complete well finally I'm
remember when I was gonna do miss New
York Teen New York no wait Miss New York
teen you we're a team but it was like a
year ago no it was like five years ago
oh yeah I think I'm gonna do it now
finally I did a phone interview and like
the woman loved me and then like when I
never answered an email I think she was
like really upset I'm sure she was you
know he should reach out to I love it
hope oh I mean if you can get her on the
phone but if you can't Raquel James's
girlfriend you know I'm good
maybe she can give you some tips and
tricks I'm okay bringing James get
struck is he's like my girlfriend's
gonna bring Miss USA okay
with all the stress this is why she got
into it with all the stress quote I have
to keep my mind busy she tells us and
her body building after getting into
yoga I was looking for the next thing
she says I also wanted to show my
daughter's that if you put hard work and
time into something you can achieve
anything I think it's a it's a great
message to be sending I'm sorry it's
like a little weird just cuz like I
think they look freaky like well that's
Tamra looked freaky like all bodied
others that's that's the vibe where's
the beach like it's [ __ ] weird I
really don't like it okay
it's not a fan of body yeah that's part
of the competition I'm not a fan of
bodybuilding like whatsoever
clearly but I think it's nice to aspire
toward something so healthy so just have
a goal weight like okay but like I don't
know we should do a tough mudder
today is Wednesday so that obviously
means your toasters even though I don't
know why I say obviously because we
legit have been like doing it on random
days for the past month but we're back
on track Wednesday Jacob's back so we
got our [ __ ] together tear toasters it's
basically our unsolicited advice segment
if you have an issue with a friend a
roommate a boyfriend a lover a family
member or just anything you need help
with feel free to email dear toasters at
gmail.com and we will do our absolute
best to read them live they're
completely anonymous especially if you
want them to be well not Nate below
anyone's identity we don't use real
names but it's just really interesting
it makes me feel a lot better about
myself to see some of the [ __ ] you guys
are going through the word lover is
officially ruined for me after watching
Sex in the City
matte episode they're buying to review
like my TV wasn't so expensive I would
have third and something on it a bottle
of perfume perhaps yeah like I have a
she's the worst ideally I mean you guys
have to watch the second past episode
for justice for us when Carrie Falls you
guys did you see my boomerang I deserve
a Pulitzer you do not a Pulitzer like an
Oscar you'll make sure it's for like
photography it's like yeah I think so
we're just a Nobel Peace Prize will do
but um I can't believe I forgot that
that happened well it's yours for
writing okay my caption got a pillow
code sir with my dear toaster my
boomerang will get a Nobel Peace Prize
okay bachelorette party of work question
mark one of my closest friends is
getting married in the fall across the
country and I'm spending quite a lot to
travel out there and I'm photography in
all the festivities for the big day
her maid of honor just sent out dates
for a bachelorette party slash bridal
shower weekend in our hometown where I
currently live and I don't know if I can
go wait but that's the only food across
the country I've been a nanny for the
family of a professional athlete for
several years now nice first to pay my
way through grad school and now for
extra cash a couple of long weekends a
year and I've already committed to nanny
for them that entire week I don't know
what to do because this girl is an
amazing
they really want to be there for her
especially because it's in town but I
don't want to back out of my commitment
to this family plus that money is
helping me fund my trip across the
country for the wedding help what do I
do
well doing the right you're doing the
right you said that the mean of honors
sent a bunch of date options just tell
her you can't do this specific date and
if you're close enough friend that
should be important and like that if
they still choose that date you you gave
them morning look you're good you're in
the clear and you know what you really
want to pick up that relationship like
that guy could become really famous soon
and like you would want to be his go-to
nanny
yeah and Billy how far out are we
talking like if it's months like he
could get another nanny and also it's
like in your house - is he what's his
contract you're gonna go all across the
country like and pay your way to be
there for things for her if you just go
to this one thing in your town that's
another thing across the country that
you don't have to go to you know actual
wedding is across the country she has to
go to that part but she says that she's
been doing a lot of stuff like maybe it
was our would you rather someone come to
your bridal shower a bachelorette party
and something else or just your wedding
I mean it depends on the person
totally but if they're really close like
one of your friends red obviously the
wedding I guess like the wedding there's
so many people there I may that's not a
party like oh and many people I want the
real deal totally you know so this isn't
like a terrible situation to be in
either way you're doing a nice thing
yeah they're your friend or your
employer and you know you can ask for
more happens
[ __ ] happens people have conflicts
recommend a different date let me know
how it goes next up creepy guy friend
I've been best friends with this guy for
the past five years let's call him Joe
when Joe and I first met we went on like
two dates but decided we were better as
friends fast forward to now we are both
in relationships and all get along go on
double dates etc I become good friends
with Joe's girlfriend and she's no
problem with our friendship
more recently Joe mentioned to me that
his girlfriend is pushing marriage but
he doesn't feel like he's ready yet he
said he can see himself spending his
life with her however he feels like he's
not mature enough and he would want to
hook up with other people but doesn't
want to break things off with this
girlfriend
okay he's sleazy after that conversation
that I dama can our friendship
drastically changed now every time we
talk he is being uncomfortably for
purchase saying inappropriate things to
me acting like he's hitting on me and
crossing a line of friendship he has
turned into a complete perv I'm not
Sydenham and it's giving me the biggest
pit not to mention I'm good friends with
his girlfriend
do I tell it's got from everything
that's been going on this girl is
expecting a proposal by the end of the
year and her man is out here talking to
me like he's single and talking all this
other [ __ ] on their relationship what am
I supposed to do well whatever you do do
not get involved because it's not your
[ __ ] business do not go talk to the
girl seriously stop like don't even let
that become a thought in your head and
you know what just like I'm so tired of
people like involving me in their own
[ __ ] you know what I mean like you
mean the premises no I mean like if you
have a problem like you want me to talk
to your friend about it like [ __ ] you
like we're adults handle your own [ __ ]
and get the hell away from me so like
and also this is what I'm doing you're
washing your hands a bit this is
something that I feel like a lot of
people can learn from like if you have a
friend and they're not being very
friendly and they're not acting like a
friend that you want to hang out with
anymore stop hanging out with them when
friends are replaceable and this you met
this girl through him so she can't be
that close with her so who cares if you
lose that friendship he's being annoying
and flirty and creepy so who cares if
you lose that friendship move on get new
friends in the words of Beyonce sorry I
want to start that joke again Beyonce
was wrong
you are Arab oh wait you're Arab plate
no you are replaceable right right
like some people in your life that are
not replaceable like I have friend said
if they started acting weird I would
take the necessary measures to bring
them back into the final idiot there's
like four people I do that far for sure
but those are the four people anyone
else in my in my circle if you're
starting to be like take away from my
life experience scram no Jackie you know
exactly what I'm talking about like I
have a friend you know uh-huh who's just
an absolute torture and and I'm not
gonna go out of your way to make her a
better person you know and that's who
she is and two you can just not hang out
with her and you know what I'm better
off because of it right so get new
friends get new friend also these people
weren't even your friends before so
break down with your other friends no
double date with someone else yeah
that's my solution hang out with someone
else stay out of their drama this girl
if she you know has a brain which she
probably does she'll pick up on what's
going yeah when she doesn't get em
proposal by the end of the air she'll
figure it out yeah or like there's no
way that he's acting one way towards you
and then another way towards her then
he's a sociopath and she'll figure that
out right okay people are smarter than
you think yeah sorta I'm like
but like what goes on behind closed
doors like you just you can't even
imagine it's so true you know so like
she if he's a creepy freak like she
knows no can only hide for your real
self for so long I got my hair blown out
yesterday in my house and like a bed was
like getting ready for basketball and he
was like making such a mess and I
literally spent the whole afternoon
cleaning like it was so blatantly
disrespectful like right in front of my
eyes like like I wasn't even there and I
literally start looking nagging at him
like I was being kind of a [ __ ] I was
just like towel water bottle closet like
calling things for him to do Windex like
you pick it up and I was doing my hair
and I was just like I need to stop doing
this in front of strangers like I'm
literally being an animal and it's like
you can't hide your true self and I
can't imagine what he thought happens
after he leaves
do you know to me right but really
that's as bad as it is no you being such
a [ __ ] like tell wet carpet bed Joris
he leaves all the drawers open with my
clothes
Vasili get out yeah and I'm like closet
isn't the closet door open with our
dirty laundry I'm like that's nice
really [ __ ] nice laundry closet pick
it up I was being such a mom that's
funny did he do those things yes and but
like literally like rolling his eyes at
me like a toddler very if the shoe fits
very lovely okay next up boyfriend's
sister problem okay thanks to a post
high school glow-up congratulations
that's the best kind no one wants to
blow up before high school because then
it's all downhill the post high school
blow up is where it's at you already
have it going on
I finally snagged my childhood crush at
28 years old
okay very much childhood crush say his
name please like child my firm when I
was a child like when you were in like
middle school oh there were a few oh
there were so many I like loved Bradley
garson's he I mean I see oh wow and he
was like not into girls like not that he
was into words he was just like
completely uninterested in like talking
to girls and like I took it to taupe
and I just liked him so much and
sometimes I go look in the Facebook he's
still cute wait there were three of them
there was one it was great to me too
they were just like there is one oh and
their parents were so nice if there was
such a nice family yeah I'm gonna go
look him up at this
I finally sang my childhood crush at 28
years old so in five years you could end
up with Bradley who I dedicated journals
to from ages 11 to 16 okay journals what
a nerd do you remember when we were in
Nashville you guys not this time the
last time and we like hired freelancers
to do it to run our show for us and
Olivia create for those our new
listeners Olivia was one of the best
episodes of our show of all time of all
time Olivia Creedy Nashville The
Hangover I was oh
not okay and she's just talking and I
was literally Center I'm like [ __ ] I
cannot do anything say like please just
talk so she came she was basically a
host she was talking about her she was
seeing this guy in Nashville she was
like loving living in Nashville and she
was singing Scotty was going really well
there was a couple weird things about
him they like hadn't had sex I just made
out and he journal she was like it was
so weird like when I found out like I
was really like turned off by it and I
went on this like legit 3-hour rant
about how journaling in general
especially boys who journal are like
enormous losers and it turns out one of
the freelancers that we hired he journal
too so that was really fun
I know Cuddy it was like does anyone in
this room journal who's it and he was
like I do I find it very therapeutic and
I was like good for you I was so fake
okay we've been dating for the past
eight months and it feels like the real
deal we talk about marriage and kids all
the time and we're moving in together in
a week everything's going well except
Dada his younger sister in high school /
college we were friends and recently
realized we were neighbors so we have
gone to grab a drink here and there her
brother my boyfriend started coming
around and asked me out on a date
we both separately asked her if she was
okay with it and she was totally fine
and approved we tried this girls the
same great as a sister or they were just
like friends most high school and then
through that friendship she met she
reconnected with Brad I know it's very
serious um and now it's she thinks it's
the real deal they've been dating for
eight months
we'll call this guy Bradley what up
um then she called mr. J's okay it's a
few time not free time then she started
going through a bad breakup with her
boyfriend and it was like the tables had
turned now she has convinced all of her
friends that we went behind her back and
was texting me daily saying that I
ruined her relationship with her brother
and acting like a crazy ex-wife I've
been taking the high road for the past
eight months and not responded as to not
ruin my potential relationship with his
parents and other sisters but I don't
know what to do do I confront her and
tell her to get over it do I keep taking
the high road I'm a classy lady so I
would never fight but she doesn't seem
to be showing any signs of slowing down
this crazy train I'm starting to worry
I'll see her alone in public and won't
know how to react help I'm so glad I
don't know any of the people that you
guys write in about because they sound
horrible like this is just comes like an
absolute [ __ ] nightmare and coming
from someone Ben has one sister and they
are super super close so it's definitely
there's there's a way to do it you can't
be a [ __ ] and you can't like take over
and you have to be understanding that
like they need their alone time but this
girl sounds crazy and today it's far
away from her as possible we share and
continue to take the high road and you
do if you do ever run into her in year
one or one on one like feel free to give
her a tongue-lashing um I would say just
don't put anything in text noting that
she never leave a paper to construe if
you need to say something to her do it
in person a loan when you can't hold it
in anymore
but trying to take the high road as long
as you can because once the toothpaste
is out of La Mirada it'll remember her
friendship forever
yeah and just continue to be sweet as
sugar to everyone else in his family so
that like when she tries to talk [ __ ]
about you like she looks crazy wait wait
and if you start drama with the sister
like your stock like lowers wares like
you're trying to you're trying to get
the ring like you're trying to impress
the parents like you want to be the
whole package there you don't want to
give them a reason to like see something
bad about you you know what I mean yeah
I'll say because I'm never gonna take
your side over the sisters no so you
have to just act like there are no sides
we're we're all good high road high road
last one I can't look at his feet
anymore so my boyfriend and I are a
happy little couple but there's one
problem he is in desperate need of a
serious pedicure I've mentioned this to
him several times and even often even
offered to take him with me to my
favorite nail salon where lots of other
girls also bring their boyfriend for
some foot care very normal very normal
he refuses every time saying that men
don't get chick pedicures then I suggest
using
l clipper trim and apply some cuticle
oil or lotion I gave him my nail care
kit and showed him how to use it he
didn't use it we have a very honest and
open relationship and usually when I ask
him to do something or he ask me to do
something we'll do it but for some
reason he just refuses to take care of
this gross situation I'm embarrassed to
go to our pool with him for fear that
other pool robbers might glance at his
feet and run away in fear I literally
cannot snuggle with him unless I'm sure
he's wearing socks please help me he is
truly the love of my wife but I will not
trim his toenails how do I politely
demand that he take care of his feet
without being a giant [ __ ] like boys
who wear like pedicure it's like what a
douche bag
literally everyone I know gets pedicures
and manicures literally once a week our
dad 50 years sakata a manicure yes very
normal
he needs to but you need to be a we're
going on a surprise like on his birthday
like and just get him in a pedicure
chair or call up one of those circles
good luck on your house I'll come to
your house no one will see him getting a
chick pedicure only honestly he's also
someone who uses the word chick like
yeah maybe you need a new boyfriend
honest I know but that's like no I'm
kidding she used the term love of year I
think you don't use that term loosely so
and really if you do have an open
relationship like there's absolutely
nothing I could say or like I would be
embarrassed to say or do in front of
been which is probably a problem like I
shouldn't draw the line somewhere but
like that's the best type of
relationship and also if you do have an
open relationship like why isn't why
isn't he being receptive to your request
I want to hear about that girl from last
week who you know what you should do
told her boyfriend about the breath when
you're cuddling and he's like his toes
are out you should like just crush
scratch yourself and start bleeding be
like oh your toes yeah that and then be
like listen now that you've named me you
have to go get a pedicure I'm still
doesn't I wonder what happened the girl
from last week who like whose boyfriend
really developed poor breath and she was
like trying to talk to him about it I
would like I would like an update yeah
so we should make a new email dear
toasters update yeah yeah dear updates
at Gmail are calm yeah okay
so Jackie and I have to run because we
have an extremely busy afternoon filled
with lots of research and development we
are recording our podcast with the one
the only NT tonight I mean today we'll
edit it and then it'll be up like a
little bit later today well obviously
post on Instagram when it's up and we're
gonna do an Instagram post please feel
free to comment all of your questions on
our next Instagram posts for Auntie
different threads you want him to talk
about different blinds you wanted to
talk about
general questions for him we're super
excited I'm a little nervous if we don't
if like if if tomorrow we're not here
understand what happened to us okay for
us it's been an absolute pleasure
hanging out with you if you're a new
toaster or you just randomly stumbled
upon this video the morning toast is a
live morning millennial morning the
morning shows is alive morning mmm the
morning toast is alive millennium
morning show where we talk about the
things you care about where we wish
Millennials a good morning
we're live every Monday through Friday
that's the weekdays we definitely don't
collab on the weekends Monday through
Friday 10:30 a.m. Eastern Time we're
live on Facebook we're live on YouTube
to make sure you like both of us there
and then we're also available in the
podcast app so make sure you subscribe
give us five stars all that good stuff
we will see you tomorrow